[Music]
guys i have a story i thought was
pretty interesting because i have never
heard of
like if i wanted to go and clean
someone's
bathroom that i would have to pay them
to clean it but apparently that's gross
common thing
on this one street called c streets
in sri lanka where people that want to
go
and clean the bathrooms there have to
pay the owner
to clean the bathroom i'm so confused
everything you just said not a fetish
sounds like something japan would do you
know
why oh fetish it's like yeah come and
clean my bathroom
oh yes i will and i'll pay you yeah
so it's not a fetish i still don't
understand the story's not complete
right yeah there's more of this right
it's kind of like wait can i pay you to
buy you groceries
can i come over and do your chores and
then pay you yes
you know that's basically what it is
it's exactly that can i pay you and suck
your dick weight actually no that that
makes sense
it makes sense if you're like can i pay
you to beat you up hm
uh no is it like what like a breaking
room does for people
relieve some sort of tension why just
clean their own bathroom maybe they
that that's what they do they're good to
clean
are the bathroom owners just extremely
attractive so they're like oh i'm
cleaning your
your private zones well no this is uh
this is a common thing on this street
it's a cacao street so it's like all so
businesses on this street
get paid for people to clean their
bathrooms okay enough guessing is it red
like district street no they're like i
just want to clean these hoes toilets
there is zero sex involved in this damn
why people not horny i'm not smart
enough to get this
ah it's hurting my brain it's like
it's like a riddle like why would you
pay to pay
i mean to clean someone else exactly why
it's an attraction like i don't know
these streets
nice bathroom you're like oh is it rich
people's houses
because they just want to go into the
house and see mmm no what it looks like
you're getting kind of a little bit warm
i'll get some
hey sri lankan [ __ ] would you
eat tofu
that smell like [ __ ] and then i don't
know why people would eat tofu that
smell like [ __ ] i'm like exactly cause
you're not taiwanese yeah [ __ ]
all right the reason why people pay the
owners to clean
the this re their restrooms is because
these are
jewelry stores so the the people making
the jewelry they sweat and gold
dust particles go on their body so
before they leave their shift at these
jewelry stores
they go to the bathroom in the back and
they shower
and so these people that are paying the
owner to
to wash their bathroom they're actually
collecting the
the gold dust wow they're ingesting it
i mean it's like an investment i'll give
you three dollars let me clean your bat
yes
and i can keep the gold yes and they
they might come out
they're turning a profit wow they have
to be there's this one guy that got
interviewed
and he says not once has he ever like
lost money
so the the gold is not going down the
drain or is there like a screen there
uh at least cash yeah and why aren't the
workers just catching all the [ __ ]
gold dust and keeping it that's good
they call it wastage
like they don't they don't like it i
don't care i'm covered
i'm working with the real [ __ ] yeah yeah
i'm so rich
does that mean most of it's actually
really going down the drain well
can you imagine being covered in gold
every day yeah like little tiny little
particles i'm going to show you guys a
video clip so you guys can see for
yourself like the process and stuff and
how
good i need evidence panning for gold
this one particular guy that's getting
interviewed the reason why he does this
is because he's actually he's been
addicted to heroin since he was a
teenager so
to maintain his addiction and to sustain
his family
he's still responsible as a heroin
addict yes
wait till you find out how they even get
the gold too it's like crazy okay here
we go
just habit and
if someone asks about my job i say i'm a
goldsmith
and one day a craftsman works at the
table may waste 20 milligrams of gold
because they sweat the gold sticks to
the craftsman's bodies
when they shower it all gets disposed
here
in order to clean a bathroom or toilet
on the sea street it's a cleaner must
pay the owner
somewhat like a wheel of fortune it's
unpredictable
after cleaning the slops i take the dirt
and wash it out
finally i save the sand which may
contain gold dust
wow what you see here is gold he is
panning for gold from shower
what did you add acid why acid
the acid will dissolve all the unwanted
copper bronze silver lead
wow and leave behind only the gold
what the after rubbing it with mercury
when you see here the chocolate color
that's gold
what are you adding this is borax
there's so many dangerous things there's
no technology involved it's just our
skill
our method is very quick how much will
you get
for this whoa it weighs about 2.5
manchad i can get 2500 to 2700 rupees
13 to 14 dollars for this huh and so he
is
dabbling in all those chemicals yes
isn't that what you got oh sri lankan
breaking bad
with gold 14 bucks i wonder if it's
daily if he makes that every day
true i don't know if it is like because
they shower every day right
yeah they probably might be yeah and how
many hours of work is that that might be
a lot of money it looks like just like a
couple hours of work i don't know
and sometimes you get lucky it
definitely looks like this is a
situation where
if they don't have a conventional drain
that's why because
i'll think of a normal bathroom where
they have a normal drain where
everything just goes down
this one seems like it just kind of goes
into the outside the street
it looked like the the water just kind
of
there's like a uh like a like what do
you call it like it's level to flow down
and then and then there was like a catch
yeah yeah and then he was the one that
was kind of filtering it yeah yeah
so he was saying that he might spend one
rupee and earned
and earn 10 rupees i mean no wonder he's
doing all that heroin it's like you're
covered in chemicals and you're probably
in pain from all that [ __ ]
that's actually what he's saying that
he's in pain he didn't
he didn't elaborate yeah because heroin
helps take away pain right
so he's saying that heroin is his
medicine and that he would love to
eventually not depend on heroin and so
actually
at the end of this video because this
was filmed before the pandemic
and it says that due to the pandemic he
no longer is able to do this kind of job
and so his family tucked him into like a
rehab
so he's been wow yeah what if he's so
used to just start scrubbing the rehab
floors over there
and he starts making gold yeah he's like
i'm just used to this [ __ ]
like i need i need to have some purpose
and [ __ ] yeah but now he's on the road
to recovery
it's crazy that he even though he's a
he's addicted to heroin that he still
does honest work
you know like he's not stealing he's not
beating people up robbing people
like how do you even learn how to do
this and and he
he can make enough to take care of his
family and get a little bit of opium or
heroin
you know yeah damn that's kind of nuts
seeing [ __ ] like that though
i'm just like dude isn't it crazy that
like
this cup of coffee right here can pay
for this man's whole entire week or some
[ __ ] like that
that's [ __ ] crazy like the amount of
even the poorest people in america are
still a part of the
like five percent of the richest people
in the world the poorest people in
america isn't that crazy yeah
like we're still complaining it's all
relative right because if you're in
public housing because like
out here like let's say you're on
welfare right yeah you still eat
good compared to the rest of the world
not that they have it good i'm just
saying compared to like people in real
poverty
like in another country like like you
you still have appliances you still have
a stove you still have
um our basic quality of life isn't bad
it's bad but it isn't
yeah like philippines extreme yeah yeah
extreme like some
you know like we have friends who just
like uh when they came here they didn't
have like
regular appliances you know and then now
they do
and they're just like you don't know
what real poor is i feel you my cousins
too in the philippines as well like
when i go to their house you know where
like essentially the shower is the same
place as their
living room yeah i mean everything's so
close together like the bathroom's there
and stuff and the you know the water and
you have to heat the water
i mean the guests heat the water right
because
they're used to the cold showers they
can't even find matching shoes huh
i mean they're like there's a lot of
things that we definitely
take for granted and that i'm there and
i'm like i want to i want to help out
and that's me being
you know freaking american like they're
happy
with what they have yeah yeah because we
come in like poor people
and then they're happier than we are
chasing chickens and [ __ ] yeah they're
much happier than we are it's like
camping every day you know
and we're the ones like this the whole
time not even engaging
no and our eyesight's getting all [ __ ]
up because we're not exercising
yeah thinking we need more and more
money that lasik you know what i'm
saying
hey iq laser vision
when was the first time you guys seen
real poverty like outside of america
mexico mexico yeah vietnam
my my mom's childhood home looks pretty
crazy
in mexico i think mine was thailand and
i was like
13. like i lived in a hmong village for
a month
wow which which is like there's thailand
and of course there's like poverty like
but then um i don't think hmong people
are registered as citizens
so they just have to fend for themselves
by the uh
they just live in the mountains and so
it's crazy how resourceful like the
people are they just live off the land
and they figure out ways to like sell
[ __ ] or whatever and then they buy
like trucks and and building materials
and then they just hook themselves up
and i'm like
how's this even possible because when
we're born and raised here in the states
like
it's almost like we think the streets
and the houses and this
everything is natural like when you're a
child right you kind of like
you're kind of born into it it's like
yeah it's just you're born into this
world
with the system already in place yeah
and then where you get
food is like you open up the fridge yeah
it's there right
so you don't think like oh that was
killed
that was picked from the ground like you
know but then you don't
see it until you're there every single
day and you see the whole
process happening like they killed the
pig they put it in a [ __ ] pot
they made soup like all this [ __ ] goes
down
and then i was like damn this is crazy
like everything is so like from the
earth yeah it sounds stupid because it's
like duh but
when you're like nine or ten and then
well i was 13 or 14 at the time
you know you hear about it and you watch
videos in it but it's much different
when you're living
in it it feels like you're camping every
day and it's like survival
instead of like glamping yeah i don't
think it's stupid because i think like
if i were to
even now right like i'm a very picky
eater but i think if i were to live that
experience i think i'd be like
[ __ ] you [ __ ] a [ __ ] why are you being
so particular like
just go for it you know because like
look at the process look at everything
it took to get to here
you know and then i think i'd be way
more appreciative um there is a video
that reminds me of this in the
philippines
that got viral on facebook and i forget
what they call it but this guy
he's showing the process of going into
like a trash heap or a dumpster
was it 90 day fiance collecting
at philippines right that's not because
ed was in the philippines yeah yeah and
he saw
a rat in his girlfriend's house and he's
like is that a rat and she's like
yes and then he's all like i'm not
taking a shower there
yeah he was being all yeah it's just a
[ __ ] rap
but i mean yeah there it's normal but he
this guy
he goes out to the dumpsters after
people eat and he collects
like the the meat off the bones and
stuff and and he makes it into a meal
and sell and cook re-cooks it and into
small bags and then like the poor people
come to his shop to buy it
you know what i mean wow they can it's
really like the poorest
people because their stomachs can handle
it and stuff and he's like
it's not for everybody you know um but i
forget what it's called
or something like that but you just
realize like how lucky you are because
they're just waiting on people
to waste food hopefully or even just off
the bones and he makes a meal
out of that that's insane and this is in
the philippines
this is in the philippines yeah it this
is a huge video on on facebook but
it reminds me of it i mean he's he's
going for gold but this guy is even
going the next step where he's getting
food
to sell so he can get money hopefully
and
how resourceful he is that's crazy
[Music]
you